oh [__] you mother [__] been asking
yourself with joy where you've been you
got inside hand a paint on mine list I
never forget about nobody I'm doing my
own things
I'm just trying to put the [__]
pieces together but uncle Joey never
went no way you understand me I love
your [__] too much to go
anywhere I was just planning my next
[__] move
oh [__] I got some [__] death
here in a jar that you're at that time
for you [__] with the proof
could really [__] around here no more
lot of amateurs out there trying to run
game when you're [__] uncle
Joey's here to stop these [__]
fools they think I just came off the
[__] banana boat yesterday they don't
know they have no idea who the [__] they
think that dealing with you understand
me
but it don't matter cuz we're here and
we'll [__] quit oh yeah
uncle Jovi here never [__]
fiercely and dick and giving our
chopsticks it's Thursday
you showing up with a [__] harmonica
and a big dick and I'm saying who gives
a [__] you're gonna harmonize him to
death before they suck that high mammal
that's what Harvey [__] up uncle Joey
here repping the Comedy Store hat what
are you [__] kidding me or what I'm
back [__] the Marines are back with
listen the reason what happened around
lately is I've been busy I'm working on
a new show and up get few people pretty
soon we got the church we had a lot of
things going on you understand me don't
worry about nothing next [__]
week Philadelphia Parks casino sold out
sorry you didn't make your move Saturday
night DC 9:30 club so now you didn't
make your [__] move the 29th go
228 went Wilbur theater in Boston sold
out you didn't make a move and what's
left is tickets for a Foxwoods casino
that's all you got so that's the only
date this [__] Saturday night the
Icehouse sold out we don't [__] around
here you understand me we're taking it
to the hoop Joey bananas has slinging
out dick and giving a [__] little
Chinese Mass when you get on a plane you
don't get sick anyway joy which would be
a beatin was sparking off with sparking
a death today
my friends over there the urban trees I
want to get my shot out of them in Tora
Boulevard they got the weed over there
they give Jerry's kids before they put
them on the swing you know I'm saying
look at these percentages over here the
banana og okay look at this percentage
right here up on top 28.2 you see that
right there twenty eight point two
[__] we're not [__] around
here you want to keep smoking that
susquehanna do it on your time do not
even think of doing it on my
[__] time look at this one here
this is twenty five [__] percent you
understand me you want to smoke those
kind of the numbers you got a run with
the King of Swing right now look at this
one crew you know why they call it crew
cause when you smoke this thing you got
kicked in the head by a Thai guy don't
get me started on the Thai guy that took
the twelve kids in the cave he was gonna
[__] those guys in the ass but we'll
talk about that [__] on stage
look at this percentage here twenty
seven percent for you [__] who
think that you're smoking like that
you're smoking [__] glue that's what
you're smoking you dumb [__] you gotta
come out here with uncle Joey and let's
get down without a frown but anyway Joey
what is this a museum let's smoke some
[__] reefer here
I already smoked the crew now I'm gonna
smoke a little bit of this banana oh gee
it almost killed me last night he had
spots all over he kept looking around
like a [__] Momo
that's the type of weed I'm [__]
sporting you want to smoke susquehanna
go hang out with your buddy down there
and you can smoke all the susquehanna
you want
calmly store tonight 10:45 be they'll be
there be there or be [__]
square you follow me the two podcasts
there I'd already finally morning two of
my open mic is you know we're just doing
our job over here [__] I got the
daughter I got the podcast I got the
wife and I'm trying my best to be a
[__] comic and I got a podcast and
you know I got no time to [__] around
for [__] [__] around
whereas they say in Spanish no tango
game I'm American anyiah
booked I miss him it didn't get my mom
and I beating our so it's third Labor
Day weekend I didn't come at your
Monday's cuz I knew you were out [__]
long and jumping up and down playing
volleyball at the beach thinking you're
cool but you know what [__] the
reality is is the fourth quarter [__]
if you don't pull it together now next
thing you know it's gonna be [__]
Christmas senior be sitting there like a
[__] mortadella on the couch with no
presents and they know give me a [__]
you following me you gotta get it
together your year starts right now this
is when I go to double work double time
for uncle Joey now I already had
meetings this morning I [__] wrote
this Lorne had took my kid to school
listen it's all over I don't [__] around
ain't got time to be [__] around
neither do you unless you're on a boat
didn't your dick sucked with that
Chinese guy that got beat up by United
and 12 of his [__] in Vic's on a
[__] boat sniffing your [__] pipe
you gotta get up every day and also
would [__] two legs here I'm like an
octopus I'm out getting money I got a
eighty [__] hands I got one money in
your pocket you know the [__] thing I
got it up your ass and the other thing
is smelling the finger that was up your
ass and I'll be [__] knows I ain't
[__] around no more
why because why the [__] up I've been
doing this for 27 years to [__] sit
at home and make jokes by myself I gotta
get out there and see you [__]
late all that's left is Fox was that's
the end of the month and then October we
started up again with West Palm Beach
and then I go to [__] Cleveland to
see my peeps over that steep in my
orchard chick chick chick chick chick
and the [__] Cleveland family who you
know I love with all my heart but joy
what's the story we're gonna spar are
you gonna tell the stories about they
pissed on me and Cleveland no let's
[__] spark we'll talk about pastrami
in Cleveland when it's time to pelipper
astronomy and [__] Cleveland
right now we're talking about the Comedy
Store
you [__] me and how we love
each other now everything's [__]
perfectness hey we're family I don't
with you you're with me and these
punk-ass [__] they want to be with us
you follow me [__] if you see I
[__] up my I brought a little bit but
I don't give a [__] who like I'll
impress I'm 55 I don't need to impress
nobody
I gotta gonna do [__] to sit in the back
like a fat [__] blue belt and get
beat up by 30 year olds but I do it
every [__] day you know why cuz every
day I got a little bit better every day
you get a little bit better just a
little bit better maybe one day you can
pick up your leg a little higher
I got no shame I show up you gotta keep
showing up [__] it's like this
weed thing I smoke every [__] day 30
days the [__] when we kind of do it [__]
you see me going crazy you see me took I
mind my business I don't bother nobody
nobody season me you don't see me at
parties jumping up and down crew nothing
I don't wanna see nobody understand I
got my reef I got my kids I got my
little jujitsu gym I go kick box a
little bit I don't bother nobody
oh this is it remember who gives you
[__] I'm with you you with me and these
punk-ass [__] wanna be with us they
want to be with us then six weeks later
when they don't get what they want they
start [__] crying like [__] on the
internet unbelievable and never [__]
ends but that's it and that's that we're
down to the [__] ground here it's
towards the end of the year so if you
don't make it happen ain't nobody gonna
make it happen for you
always you remember that everybody think
somebody's in an SW I do dick freeze
ain't nobody gonna do dick unless you
make the first [__] move and I'm
saying that's what second chances are
about your move [__] everybody's
watching where's Lewis CK he's making
I've showed up one day and he don't come
back you gotta come back the next day
louis c.k what the [__] who gives a [__]
what they say you show up one day you
gotta show up the next night and a
different [__] club and make them
talk to make him go crazy is he gonna
make people go crazy without knowing
they going crazy and you're sitting in
the back like a master of puppets'
[__] [__] with that I got
I'm [__] up little girl [__] up you
fight with me sometimes you [__] up
you can't do nothing
sometimes you're [__] up and you're
ready to stab [__] that's the
way I am right now I'm [__] up with a
minute stab [__] and so should
you
listen I'm 55 I got nothing you guys are
young you got the world by the balls why
you sitting there why you sitting there
get up there go out there take what
[__] belongs to you don't you want to
live like a [__] doctor it's right in
front of you but they're not gonna hand
you the map you follow me they're not
gonna hand you the map [__] you
gotta figure that one out on your own so
do what you need to do that's more a
couple more puta Lutz's and i'll see you
in the next couple days why cuz I love
you that's the type of party of this
weight think somebody's are not gonna
dog with an envelope full of counterfeit
twenties I wish those days are long gone
I'm saying but what are you gonna do
every day you gotta just you gotta be a
little bit better than the day before
that's it that's all I do every day I
thought it'd be a little bit better than
[__] yesterday [__] soap October
could suck my dick I'm smoking reefer
every day I just don't do anything else
I just move out even I haven't had an
edible and [__] weeks why not
does it joke we've moved on from edibles
I'm thinking about doing heroin I just
gotta see if I get this Chinese importer
to mail it to me Ovi don't [__] around
with the Mexican heroin
that's what [__] up Demi Lovato when
she waited wish she wasn't writing
anything out of this world
the Chinese heroin that's what Jimmy pay
at all those [__] are banging
out coming up with songs Aerosmith sorry
I got a direct line the [__] Thailand
you know I gotta [__] talk to that
boy child molester whatever it don't
matter what matters is I'm here with you
[__] you gotta come with me and
together we're gonna take over the world
that's it and that's that
oh that's the one that killed John
McCain listen I love you [__]
Feli thank you very much for coming to
the shows and supporting me DC I love
you I'll be in the nation's capital next
weekend slinging dick then in two weeks
I'll see you savages are getting Boston
I can't wait for the world with data and
then we got [__] what's the other one
we got [__] Foxwoods that's it anyway
stay black have a great [__] day
forget don't forget don't let nobody
[__] with you and always remember in the
back of your head or you take the ink
and my matter of being high up with
Julio your I said it they're gonna come
I might tell mmm more wrong wrong but
then again I might they'd do it okay
forget that that rohnke lot more wrong
oh yeah I love your mother [__] on my
right don't take [__] from nobody and go
for your [__] dream all right don't
let nobody stop grab the world by the
balls poke them in the eye and tell them
I own this [__] space stay black see
it mother [__] calmly store tonight
come on down
[Laughter]